have any ideas how many [ __ ] time to
shut this [ __ ] blog [ __ ] mic
doesn't work oh by the way my a7s2 got
busted $3,000 camera and this [ __ ]
mic which is 207 bucks but how are you
[Music]
hey what is going on YouTube now there
are a couple things I should have
covered that I have not done my due
diligence on I was supposed to this last
week but I have a good excuse
I was robbed huh that was terrible
now everybody by now has seen the racist
Walley world segment on Bill O'Reilly's
show where the [ __ ] goes around and
interview the whole bunch of Chinese
people asking them how they feel about
the political state of this country and
Donald Trump for what purpose you ask if
you saw this segment you would know it
was supposed to make jest of Asian
people and it obviously was trying to
make Asian people look bad racist would
be an understatement ignorant would be
an understatement just pour a comedy
would be an understatement but youyou
unfunny sack of garbage would be an
understatement
now it's been a while since I've done
this but y'all ready know what it is LG
I baby let's get let's talk first off
what [ __ ] is this about I like these
watches are they high JC Penney a night
date [ __ ] mr. miyagi is Japanese you
knew this Chinese and Japanese are even
close to being the same you want to talk
about choosing the most opposite Asian
cultures on earth just done did it
clearly dude one life's tentacle porn
and the other shoots not out their nose
like this oh yeah [ __ ] you know
this one makes electronic products that
you use from Sony and the other one
counterfeit [ __ ] from Sony and don't
even get me started on the tech londo
dude do you know karate Taekwondo is
Korean [ __ ] Korean Chinese what
uh Korean matter Parker you you know the
segment that probably pissed me off the
most was where you decided to go ahead
and interview the elderly Asian folks
you decided to use him as a cheap joke
they couldn't talk back or defend
themselves and you felt [ __ ] good
about that huh
first off if I ever saw you approach my
parents like that I would tape your dick
and staple it to your [ __ ] [ __ ]
I'm a thousand [ __ ] percent sure you
could have found or did find Chinese
Pete
in the heart of Chinatown that did have
intellectual thought about the political
representation of our country and Donald
Trump but you chose not to use those
statements and you chose not to talk to
those people
you dingleberry [ __ ] you feel good about
punking people don't you hire you a
bully aren't you being so what mother
[ __ ] hold my earrings [ __ ] you look
like Ross Geller with the chromosome
missing [ __ ] you look like the reason
why people are pro-abortion you look
like a rapist and a mistake
[ __ ] you look like Rosie O'Donnell's
fuck-buddy it's you look like one of the
dudes that went bar-hopping with Bill
Cosby mama
I could go out for days you Comedy Store
reject you are not funny now I can go on
and on for days about how terrible this
video is but let me tell you about the
bottom line number one as a comedian you
are the reason why people should throw
tomatoes and people who suck at comedy
the racism wasn't even creative at all
you were using old Asian jokes and
number two it's Bill O'Reilly come on I
think I'm not as offended as other
people and I can make Justin this
because you know Bill O'Reilly he's just
this [ __ ] self-righteous regressive
right-wing extremist [ __ ] that
happened to have a show and he caters to
those type of garbage I'm just more
offended as a comedian because somebody
was in an editing room and before they
put this out they were like oh my god
this was from a show that had
intellectual and open-minded human
beings then I probably would have had a
big issue with it it's Bill O'Reilly the
guy looks like he still gets ham and
cheese sandwiches from his mom Bill
O'Reilly looks like he masturbates the
[ __ ] that nobody else would touch
themselves but what do you guys think
did you guys expect this type of [ __ ]
where you pissed off and let me know
mama ain't trynna hey what's going on
YouTube thank you guys for tuning into
this video remember every video is gonna
be a Thursday 3 p.m. and Sunday 12 p.m.
now sometimes you will get videos that
are extra bonuses and most likely you
will actually but I know for sure on
Thursdays and Sundays you are gonna get
a video at those times so make sure you
tune in and if you want to know where
you get extra videos follow me on
Twitter Instagram and the likes and
snapchat people I'll see you out there
touch my penis
humans tend to peed your [ __ ] ass to
the lesbian mmm I expect this type of
garbage garbage god I should because I'm
making light of who I burn
somewhere over the rainbow skies are
blue